according to the johns hopkins
university website
so far there have been at least two
hundred and ten thousand reported deaths
from covet 19 in the united states
but many public health experts infected
these specialists
believe that these estimates are most
likely underestimating the actual true
number
then there are people like conspiracy
theorists who believe that the numbers
are actually being deliberately
overestimated so what's preventing us
from getting a more accurate
picture of what's going on well there
are eight points to consider
so first there's the lack of a
coordinated national surveillance system
although many of us use the covet 19
tracker
from johns hopkins university it's
important to remember that it wasn't
created as an official government source
instead it was created when a graduate
student and an associate professor
noticed a lack of systems to track cases
as a university johns hopkins can't tell
states and jurisdictions what to do
only the federal government has the
power and resources to keep everyone
coordinated
two lack of national testing and
national coordinated testing
extensive testing is only happening in a
handful of states like new york
and california and even in those places
it's not completely clear who is getting
tested and how often
so it isn't clear what percentage of
actual covet 19 cases and deaths
each state is currently catching three
lack of resources and adequate public
health infrastructure
many health departments just don't have
the personnel
the time or the technology on hand
to keep accurate records four delays in
or absence of reporting once a death
from covet 19 has happened
it needs to be reported to the
authorities and make its way
up the chain to whoever is telling the
death count at the state level
this chain may not be very well
coordinated and can make the dmv
look efficient by comparison 5.
unfamiliarity with covet 19.
we know more about the virus now
compared to when it first hit of course
but there's still a lot that remains a
mystery to medical experts
many cases can go unidentified and mixed
messaging from the federal government
hasn't helped either
6. the virus the disease it causes
and death are complex the virus can take
time to do damage and trigger chain
reaction over a lengthy period
for example if someone got kova 19
and then got pneumonia and suffered
respiratory failure the cause of death
could have been officially counted as
respiratory failure but covent 19
should also be listed in this case 7.
the lack of a clear national definition
of a covet-19
death this relates to 0.6 the federal
government should come up with a very
clear
and transparent definition of what
constitutes a covet-19
death that is properly vetted with the
scientific community
and have it released by the national
authorities eight political motivations
and conspiracy theories when politicians
seek to use covet 19 figures
as a means to their ends or conspiracy
theorists
possessing very little to no scientific
knowledge are able to sow
doubt in medically credible sources it
can become harder to determine what is
true and what is not
ultimately the death count is only one
measure of the severity of an infectious
disease outbreak
epidemic or pandemic keep in mind that
the true impact
must also be considered on impacted
families
lost economic productivity medical costs
and disruption to normal life
you